hi guys my name is Tamra chambers and
this is Tara's never seen and today we
are doing Evil Dead 3 army of darkness
oh what's that really cool evil dig
candles called let's green monsters calm
it's so cool
I'm just gonna leave it oh god if I
leave it there is it gonna yes
ouch that's painful all right well in
spirit right next to hyper guys I am
stoked to watch this to see if I like
two or three better so let's just dive
right it let's just get into it
Oh Tanner has never seen time towba fest
okay okay so I feel like people who like
number two better have a more refined
palette and people who like number three
better are like Oh big things fun I went
halfway through this movie thinking that
I liked it better I wrote in my notes
like first of all I'm already in love
with this movie it's big and cheesy and
fun and I really want to watch the TV
show now help where can I do that I
don't know Google's thing and I wrote
down I can already tell this gonna be my
favorite but then I got like halfway
through I think that I still like to
better after seeing as a whole I'm very
quick to judgements I think to is my
favorite but I still I definitely
enjoyed this one at for what it was this
movie went off the rails like Back to
the Future 3 went off the rails
completely different um
and more sense of fun but if this one
for sure who is it
so he's taken as a slave even though
he's the savior and then he meets the
obvious love interest Sheila who I end
up you and really bad for at the end ash
Bruce just he caught like hums out of
his shell in this movie more so than the
others I feel like he just makes giant
choices where he did in the first two
but there weren't as many this was just
full of choices seven thousand
get some choices support maybe that's
movie well hello mr. fancy pants so as a
slave ash is pushed into this pit and in
the pit is a very strong woman demon who
knows gymnastics ie Tamra at 12 years
old guys I used to be able to front and
back handspring now I can't even walk
upstairs and he's in the pit and this
weird priest guy like throws him his
chainsaw hand and it just clicks right
on it's just so like it's just really I
know it's just it's really just like
it's like no big deal you guys it's just
it's really cool this is the prop the
gym made it it's so cool oh it's not
even on on switch I didn't see that
before so ash shows everyone in the
little village town that he is not gonna
be messed with and it's followed by this
really cool scene where they're making
him a fake metal hand and it like
crushes something
this is groovy again is there a clip of
Jim Carrey saying groovy I feel like
there has to be a clip of him saying
that somewhere has Jim ever said groovy
have they ever been seen in the same
room at the same time just and then
Sheila comes to ashna's like you're a
hero and he treats her like a flipping
oh it's he's yucky in this scene and
then she slaps him cuz he's yucky and
then he kisses her typical okay and then
things start getting hot I was also I
was watching this while also tweeting
about the second presidential debate so
maybe I miss me so he goes to find the
Book of the Dead and he takes refuge in
this cabin and then there are three mini
ashes and they're like attacking with a
fork and then he kills them but one of
them gets inside of his mouth and he
swallows him and then he just swallows
boiling water this guy feels no pain
ash just feels no pain his head like
everything everything he does is just
kind of like oh that should hurt a mere
mortal
but I'm ash and I feel nothing should be
my slogan
I'm Tamra and I feel nothing so anyways
the swallowed small ash grows inside of
him and you'll see like a giant eyeball
on the shoulder then a second head comes
out and then they start like hitting
themselves and then they split and it's
so insane what wait what where did it
come from where did that come from
so then ash chops him up and shoots his
face which would be odd to do to
something that looked exactly like you
so then ash goes into the cemetery and
he finds the Book of the Dead but
there's three of them he's like which
will it be
and so the first one like almost pulls
him in it's like a wind tunnel and the
second one like a taxon but he fights it
off and then the third one is the book
of the The Book of the Dead The Book of
the Dead I have to say though I feel
like those were very minor
inconveniences it was just kind of like
Oh stubbed your toe what's got a
splinter here's a million dollars in
gold so before taking the Book of the
Dead he has to save these three words
that the weird priest guy gave to him to
say but he can't remember them so that
team was actually pretty funny because
he says the first two and then he just
kind of gurgles it it goes good enough
it's fine
ancient rituals more like ancient
rituals am i right give it so it doesn't
go well then you find out that he awoke
the army of the Dead bah bah bah so the
army of Darkness is awakened and it's
the just a bunch of skeletons and
there's this one scene just really quick
they're just walking walking by by the
screen and it's just some skeletons like
toting along some naked boob girl slaves
and that's the last of you see them
they're not doing anything for the army
of Darkness they're just women slaves
which is fine I just don't understand
that was just so weird I just feel like
it's a waste of time what they're not
helping you you can't have sex you don't
have penises or hearts or eyes to even
you can't even see him so it's just
weird
is it a status thing
what's going on here tell me tell me
everything I'm very curious but then the
rest of the movie is just like literally
half of the movie is just a giant fight
like a couple notable things happen like
Sheila turns into a demon and they're
cool like car thing that they made
explodes good ash fights evil ash and
he's evil Ash's trying to get the book
and and then good ash is really good at
fighting super good at fighting and like
dodging things good for you evil ash is
disposed of like the bomb and like the
catapult super neat they get the book
back
all is well Sheila's not a demon anymore
just a super super long fight sequence
something that I think is kind of funny
is Ash stays because he's like well I
have to save Sheila my love interest and
then they're like here's the potion for
you to go home he's like alright bye
Sheila peace and he like kisses her and
rides off into the sunset to drink the
potion why did he have to get on a horse
I did enjoy the end of the movie though
where he is back in s Mart and then a
demon shows up because he was supposed
to say the words that he forgot the
first time he's supposed to say those
again as he drank the potion and I guess
he forgot them again he like breaks
through with his hand and he takes out a
gun and he shoots her down and and I
assume that's where the TV show comes in
or maybe also the remake I don't know uh
but then he gets another girlfriend
immediately kisses her hail to the king
baby like okay well cool your jets a
little bit you still work at s smart and
that's and I wrote way less notes for
this episode I wrote five pages of notes
which is way less and I mean I write
each note is like this big so there's
not five pages sounds like a lot but um
I think I didn't write anything during
the fight I'm just like alright fight I
don't know what to say is there fighting
skeleton it's cool but cool s'long I
liked the second one the best it was
weird how different ash was in this
I'm pretty sure I want to be ash for
Halloween think lady I should be cool
but anyways guys that it's Evil Dead one
two and three let me know if you'd be
interested in hearing my thoughts I
wouldn't be opposed to maybe watching
the remake and the TV show and maybe
putting it on my own personal channel
Tamra Lynne shavers at youtube.com
thinking I might do something like all
do a playthrough of the Back to the
Future game that a lot of people said I
should do so maybe things in that kind
of vein that wouldn't more into an
episode here but might you know be fun
for a few people there anyways you guys
are awesome thank you for watching oh I
forgot to tell you I guess still he's
still living in the suburbs they there's
no time I haven't there's no time to
pick them up but he'll be back soon and
he loves you oh I don't know he doesn't
know you I have no ideas a baseless
claim but I do thanks for watching see
you soon
[Music]
you